( intro music )
( applause )
All right,
so I'm going to take you
on a journey back in time
to the Cretaceous Period.
Now, you might say, "Well,
I know what life was like
in the Cretaceous.
That's when T. rex was
roaming North America."
Well, I'll take you to a
very different kind of place.
I'll take you to a lost world,
an African river of giants,
a place that did not just have
one T. rex size predator,
but three.
A place that was home
to a bizarre creature
that is going to
force paleontologists
to rethink many
things they thought
they knew about dinosaurs.
Now, before we travel
back to the Cretaceous,
we'll just travel
back to my childhood.
( audience laughing )
This is how it all started.
I always loved animals,
living and extinct.
So I was equally happy
handling live snakes
on summer holidays, and
practicing my dinosaur talks
in my grandmother's
garden in Germany.
(audience laughing)
I should add that my grandmother
had no problem whatsoever
with the dinosaur part,
but she has a deep-seated
fear of snakes and crocodiles.
So, needless to say that at
least from her point of view,
things did not really get
any better as I got older.
( audience laughing )
But, I wasn't just
interested in animals.
I also really liked traveling,
and one place I
really wanted to visit
was the Sahara Desert,
not just because
it's a beautiful place, but
also because I was inspired
by the discoveries of
a German paleontologist
who over a hundred
years ago made some
incredible discoveries
in the sands of Egypt.
He found Egypt's
first dinosaurs,
and he did not just
describe dinosaur fossils.
He described crocodiles and
an entire ecosystem really,
a predator's paradise,
a very strange place.
Probably his most
important discovery
was that of a large
predatory dinosaur
he called Spinosaurus.
It's an animal that was
probably larger than T. rex
with a big sail on its back.
Some of these spines
are as tall as a person.
It was an incredible find.
It was incomplete.
The dark bones on this
image are the ones
that Stromer had found,
but it became the centerpiece
of the dinosaur exhibit
in the Munich Museum
where Stromer worked.
So his career was going well,
but things changed
in World War II.
Stromer who was
an outspoken critic
of the Nazi
dictatorship lost a lot.
He lost most of his
scientific finds
when an Allied air raid
destroyed the Munich Museum.
Spinosaurus was also destroyed,
and seemingly lost forever.
All we have are
just a few drawings.
Stromer also lost two of
his three sons in the war
after they were
drafted into the army
including the youngest one in
the middle, Gerhard, who died
just two weeks before the
end of the war in Germany.
So I was fascinated by
this dramatic story,
and by his discovery
of Spinosaurus.
So, in my early 20s,
I decided to start
a series of expeditions
to the Sahara
to explore the Cretaceous rocks
in this part of the world.
They're about 100
million years old.
About the same age as
the rocks that Stromer
was working in in Egypt.
My field work did
not take me to Egypt.
It took me to the
border region between
Morocco and Algeria,
a place called the Kem Kem.
It's a beautiful place,
and I decided to collect
everything I could find
in that environment,
crocodiles, flying reptiles,
turtles, you name it.
This here's a skull
piece from a crocodile.
I really wanted to understand
the entire ecosystem,
and it's hard work.
Most of the fossils are
found along this escarpment
so there's a lot of
climbing involved,
and it's really hard
to find good fossils.
But we found thousands of
really interesting specimens
including this one here.
It's the largest dinosaur bone
that had ever been found
in this part of the Sahara.
I found that on my
second expedition.
It's a remarkable
piece not so much
because it's so big.
It's the upper arm bone of a
large plant-eating dinosaur,
but because it belongs
to a plant-eating animal.
Because the vast majority of
the fossils we are finding
belong to predators,
T. rex sized predators,
medium-sized
predatory dinosaurs,
and crocodile-like hunters
in all shapes and sizes.
So Stromer was right.
North Africa in the Cretaceous
was a predators paradise.
One thing we noticed
was that the skulls
of all these predatory
animals were really different.
So it appears that they
were eating different things
and that may have
helped them to coexist
in the same place.
The rivers were not
just home to these
giant crocodile-like creatures.
We also have a
car-sized coelacanth,
a giant sawfish,
and even the skies were
filled with predators.
This is the largest
flying creature
ever described from Africa.
We described it in 2010,
has an 18-foot wingspan.
So we had found this
incredible ecosystem,
but really only bits and
pieces of Spinosaurus,
and that was the one that
I really, really, really
wanted to find.
But things changed
in early 2008.
We were just coming
back from the field,
and we stopped in
a city called Erfoud
on the edge of
the Sahara Desert.
It's a fairly large place,
and a man approached
me and my colleagues
and he had a cardboard
box with fossils.
They were covered in sediment.
It was kind of difficult
to tell what exactly
we were looking at,
and he asked me, "What
do you think these are?"
It was really difficult to tell,
but one piece really
caught my attention.
It was a blade-shaped section
of bone not very long,
but it had a really
strange cross section.
You can see the cross section is
the white, creamy
part of the bone,
and it's divided in two
with this big red line
in the middle.
I had never seen
anything like this.
I thought maybe this is a rib,
but maybe this is a part
of a spine of Spinosaurus.
Who knows?
I thought these are
important specimens
so I made sure that
they were brought
to the University of
Casa Blanca in Morocco,
and I thought maybe
one day I'll be able
to figure out what this is.
Well, that day came
sooner than I expected.
Two Italian colleagues
of mine told me
that a partial
skeleton of a dinosaur
that had been spirited
out of North Africa
apparently Morocco, had
gone through several hands
and, you know, had
somehow ended up in Italy,
and, you know, they said I
should have a look at it.
So when I came to Italy,
I looked at the bones
and my jaw dropped.
Tall spines.
No other dinosaur
has spines like this.
A foot that was almost complete.
We are looking at the
first Spinosaurus skeleton
that had been found
in over a hundred years.
But there was one big problem.
My Italian colleagues
didn't know where
this skeleton came from,
and that's a huge
problem in paleontology.
It means you have
no geological context.
You don't know anything
about the environment
the animal lived in,
but worst of all
you can't even prove
that all these bones were
found in the same place
and belonged to the same animal.
Maybe they were found
hundreds of kilometers apart.
So that was a big problem.
But then I looked at the
cross section of the spines
and saw something very familiar.
See the line that's dividing
the spines in cross section?
I thought that looks
a lot like this bone
I had seen in Erfoud and my
mind just started racing.
I thought so those bones
belong to Spinosaurus,
but the size, shape,
and color of these bones
and the ones I'd seen in
Morocco were so similar
I started wondering
maybe this is actually
the same skeleton.
It was a long shot,
but I thought if this
is the same skeleton
then all I need to do
( audience laughing )
is to find this one man
in the Sahara Desert
( audience laughing )
ask him to share confidential
information with me,
and show me where he found
the skeleton, and voila.
( audience laughing )
It was a crazy idea and I
knew it was a crazy idea,
but I traveled back to Morocco
and I talked to my
Moroccan colleague, Samir,
and he said, "Okay, how are
we going to find this guy?"
I mean he knows I'm crazy,
but I mean he was like
"How are we going
to find this guy?"
"Do you have a name, or an
address, or phone number?
Anything?"
But all I had was
just this mental image
of this man I had seen
several years earlier
for a few minutes in Erfoud.
So I told him, "Well,
he had a mustache."
( audience laughing )
And I'm paraphrasing
what Samir said next.
But basically he
was saying something
along the lines of
that's not an adequate
starting point for our search.
( audience laughing )
But we tried anyway.
We traveled to many
different places.
We went to places where
people were digging tunnels
into the rock looking
for dinosaur bones.
We were looking at places
where local fossil hunters
were selling things.
But we couldn't find the guy.
We couldn't find out
anything about this skeleton,
and so, you know,
we went back to Erfoud.
It was the last
day of our search,
and I was just getting
ready to give up,
throw in the towel.
So we were sitting in this cafe
in Erfoud sipping mint tea,
and I'm just thinking,
you know, that's it.
You know, I'll probably
have to give up.
It was a crazy idea.
It was like looking for a
needle, not in a haystack.
That would be easy.
I was looking for a needle
in the Sahara, one man.
So, and just at that
moment when I was
at my lowest point
and ready to give up,
this person walks
past our table.
( audience laughing )
I'm not kidding you.
At that very moment, and I
looked at the man's face,
and I look at Samir, and
I look back at the man,
and he's walking fast,
and we run down the street
and catch up with him,
and it was the man
I was looking for.
( audience laughing )
So, I couldn't really
believe my luck.
The next part,
convincing him to share
his field site with
us was the easy part.
Had never been done
before, but I was like,
I'm not letting you
go before you tell me
where you found this.
( audience laughing )
So he agreed, and here's
what happened next.
( Voice-over ): The man
agrees finally to take Nizar
to the site where the fossils
were pulled from the ground.
After nearly an hour
drive, most of it off-road,
and a 30 minute trek up
the side of a mountain,
the dealer leads Nizar
to a nondescript looking hole
in a hillside.
( mystical music )
Within minutes, in the fill
surrounding the dig site,
they discover fragments
of bones and teeth,
all but certainly Spinosaurus.
( Nizar ): This is amazing.
I mean this will take
some time to sink in,
but this is amazing.
It feels really surreal.
Calm down, Nizar, but
it still feels surreal.
( audience laughing )
It still feels
surreal to this day,
and it was amazing.
We found our needle
in the Sahara.
I'm glad I'm not a statistician
and thinking about the odds
that were stacked against us.
You know, I just
thought we'll try.
So we found the site.
We found more bones
of the same animal,
and we had beautiful
geology all around us
so we had all the
information we wanted.
So now we knew all the
bones came from one place,
and we can put the
skeleton together.
We did it the modern way.
We CT scanned all of the bones,
and built a digital dinosaur
filling in missing parts
with information we had
from other Spinosaurus
bones, isolated pieces
I had seen in
museum collections.
This is work that was
largely carried out
by Tyler Keillor.
When we put the entire
skeleton together,
we realized that we were
looking at something
that looked unlike any
other dinosaur ever found
Look at those proportions.
It's a truly bizarre animal.
And we also realized
that it was very big.
We actually mounted
it at life size,
and because that's more
impressive than a CGI model,
I'll show you our skeleton.
It's an incredible creature.
Look at that skull, a long neck,
and you'll see the big
spines that Stromer had found
over a hundred years ago.
Looks like a whale or something.
It's a truly bizarre creature.
I'm going to touch
on this very briefly
because this is
still ongoing work,
but the biology of this dinosaur
is very, very interesting.
We have a lot of really
bizarre adaptations
in this creature,
not just the big sail.
We have a nose opening
that's pushed back on the skull,
further back than in
any other dinosaur.
We have paddle-like feet,
hind limbs that
are really short.
Those are all things that
we see in aquatic animals.
Even the bone structure
of this dinosaur
looks more like that
of marine mammals
than typical dinosaurs.
and then we have these
big powerful arms
that may have been used
to tackle large prey
like the big Coelacanth
you saw earlier on.
The teeth are conical.
The snout is just like
that of a crocodile,
perfect for snaring
slippery prey.
So it turns out that,
you know, we had not only
rediscovered
Stromer's lost giant,
we were looking at the
first aquatic dinosaur.
It's a truly amazing creature.
This piece of artwork,
and all the other artwork
you saw in this talk, is
the work of Davide Bonadonna
my Italian dinosaur illustrator,
the Michelangelo of
dinosaur illustrations.
( audience laughing )
And this really shows
you what this river
of giants looked like,
a place dominated by
predators, giant fish,
flying reptiles,
and Spinosaurus,
the ruler of this
strange lost world.
So, I will leave you with
this beautiful image.
You know, for me this
encapsulates everything
that Spinosaurus was about.
It's the first aquatic dinosaur.
It's bigger than T. rex.
You know, the story
is just so rich.
It was an amazing
experience for me,
and I'm German Moroccan.
I mean this is a German
Moroccan science story.
You know, what are the odds?
But then, I don't need to
tell you anything about that.
( audience laughing )
So it was a truly
amazing adventure,
and I feel really privileged
to have been a part of it.
So I will leave you with
this beautiful image,
and a promise that I will take
you on many other journeys
back in time to
lost worlds that are
more awe-inspiring,
more thought-provoking,
and more bizarre than
we could possibly imagine.
Thank you.
( applause )
( outro music )